welcome back so we've been talking about
data science and machine learning and
you can't talk about machine learning
nowadays without talking about neural
networks so I want to give you a little
bit of an overview of what neural
networks are what they can do what they
can't do
strengths and limitations a bit about
their architecture how to program them
how to understand kind of where they
came from and what what you can do with
them now okay so neural networks are an
incredibly powerful and important aspect
of machine learning there are great
modeling capabilities of networks but I
do want to emphasize that neural
networks are not all that there is to
machine learning there's a lot more but
this is kind of one of the most
important and well used architectures
and machine learning today and part of
the reason we like them so much and the
community is adopting these so rapidly
is because they are very very expressive
architectures so so somehow a neural
network is a framework for learning
models from data and that framework has
a lot of degrees of freedom it's not
terribly constrained and so there's a
lot of expressive capability in these
neural networks they're able to capture
lots of phenomenon that we observe in in
the real world from example data sets
and it may be a more mathematical way of
describing what we mean by expressive is
that neural networks are good at
approximating arbitrary input/output
functions so if I have data with inputs
and outputs and I have enough training
data a rich enough and large enough
training data set then neural networks
are very very good at arbitrarily
approximating even very nasty
complicated input/output functions and
there's mathematical theory around this
that proves that if you have enough and
rich enough data and a sufficiently
large neural network architecture then
you can you can describe these very
complex functions now a huge caveat
something really important to mention is
that these neural networks work in the
big data limit when you have lots and
lots of
examples of your data that the data and
what the outcomes are so think of
Google's image library or Facebook's
image library they have so much training
data that most of what they you will see
in the future is somehow in that
training data and so neural networks are
great when you have vast training
datasets and when the thing you want to
use that neural network for in the
future is likely to be similar to what
you've seen in the past so I would call
that kind of an interpolation problem
neural networks are great for big
interpolation problems they can
approximate big nasty interpolators if
you have rich enough training data for
the for the past ok so that's important
neural networks have been around for a
really long time they've been around for
decades Rosenblatt came up with this
perceptron in 1958 this was well I think
the earliest neural network and this was
used for binary classification pretty
interesting idea and there was a
tremendous amount of interest and
investment and development in neural
networks for decades after this and
there's this idea that these neural
networks are mimicking some of the
functionality in biological systems and
animals you know humans and things like
that and so there was a lot of interest
both in the neuroscience community and
in the computer science and applied math
and statistics communities in what were
the capabilities of these but because of
limitations in the data and the
computational power at the time this
kind of stalled out in the the late 70s
and 80s and what's known as the AI
winter so there's this big overhyping of
capabilities the actual architectures
couldn't deliver because of limitations
of the time and so these fell out of
fashion for for decades until 2012 with
this image net challenge where deep
neural networks trained on vast datasets
in new computational architectures these
GPUs graphics processing units this kind
of culmination of big data big label
datasets much more powerful
computers and that could facilitate the
training of deep neural network
architectures really was the reviving
point for neural networks so in 2012
people couldn't believe how how
significant the performance improvement
in neural networks had become and they
beat all of the other leading algorithms
in in this image classification
challenge and since then in a very short
period of time neural networks have
risen to the top of the performance
metrics in many many many challenges
both in speech recognition natural
language processing translation image
classification and really are kind of
setting the standard for what is
possible in lots of these these
applications where you have huge data
sets and you want to do arbitrary
function approximation okay or kind of
interpolation based on your massive
massive training data set ok and I
should again point out that these neural
networks are inspired in principle by
biological systems so if you believe
that this eagle is performing this
incredible flight maneuver and control
and interacting with its environment
with its brain and its visual system
then in principle it has a network of
neurons that are performing this
incredibly complex task now whether or
not our artificial neural networks are
our silicon neural networks have
anything to do with the actual biology I
mean that's up for for grabs and and
there's lots and lots of research kind
of at the interface of neuroscience and
computer science to see what kind of
connections and comparisons we can make
what can we learn from biological
systems that will help our neural
networks what can we learn when we build
and design these neural networks that
can teach us about these biological
systems and a lot of this is actually
inspired by by visual systems in
particular these kind of multi-layered
information processing architectures
where you take very high resolution
information and pass it through layers
of abstraction and you know humans and
animals can pull out objects in motion
and
abstract that this collection of pixels
is an eagle or a word and we have these
abstractions okay and that's the kind of
thing that we want our neural network to
be able to do is take this very high
dimensional input data complex data with
lots of going on and distill out through
maybe these layers and processing
different abstractions that we can use
to build models okay
so I'll talk a lot more about what
neural networks are how they're built
the history and what is capable what our
capabilities are now and where it's
going okay thank you